the mainstream media is finally
realizing they can't hide from Carrie so
they put her on CNN on Dana bash's show
and just watch how they treat her and
watch how effective she is in her
response you called the 2020 election
corrupt Stolen Rotten and rigged and
there was no evidence of any of that
presented in a court of law or anywhere
else
that any of those things are true so why
do you keep saying that
well there's plenty of evidence we had
740 000 ballots with no chain of custody
those ballots shouldn't have been
counted the people don't trust our
elections they haven't since 2000 I'm a
reporter I've been sitting on your side
of the desk for a long time and since
2000 we have Americans who don't trust
our elections in 2000 in 2004 they
didn't trust the elections in 2016
Kamala Harris Amy Klobuchar and Hillary
Clinton everybody on the Democrat side
said the election had problems like
there definitely has been some of that
but I want to say in 2000 Al Gore
conceded in 2004 John Kerry receded and
conceded in 2016 Hillary Clinton
conceded and we didn't see that in 2020
Stacy Abrams never conceded she still
hasn't I don't hear CNN calling her an
election denier we have the right it's
protected with our first amendment to
question our government and to question
elections no questions we still have the
First Amendment yeah we still have the
First Amendment and when you start
seeing the media cancel people for
questioning their government then there
that's when we have a problem I I
totally agree about the First Amendment
you and I are uh benefiting from the
First Amendment as we speak so
you know the best part of that right at
the end of that clip there where she
says you know we have the First
Amendment and Dana Bash goes yep yep did
you see that she goes yep we have the
First Amendment yes we do
um look without rehashing all of the
election stuff the the simple fact is
that what Carrie Lake said there was
true there is it's on video we've shown
it there are the tweets Hillary Clinton
calling Donald Trump an illegitimate
president for four years the entire
machine telling you he was a Russian
plant or a Russian operative Dana Bash
knows that that's all true she knows
it's all true so Carrie is right we are
allowed to question things I don't know
I'll probably be kicked off YouTube for
saying that you're allowed to question
things but you are allowed to question
things and it's not even it's not really
about are you allowed to question things
or not it's like how about both sides
just get equal treatment so if the
Democrats want to do this if the
Democrats for four years when Donald
Trump is President want to say he's an
illegitimate president want to bring up
impeachment want to make up Russia
collusion and all of those things well
then the Republicans should just have
equal opportunity to do such things that
would be a sort of fair even playing
field but that's obviously not what we
have which is why we have corporate
press that behaves the way they do and a
big Tech machine that sensors as it
wishes